[Music]
welcome to our special guests welcome to
our partners and welcome especially to
all of you our students at Udacity we
work for you and we are humbled to serve
you every day we applaud your bravery
your determination and your grit and we
know you are going to reach your goals
and transform your life and the lives of
those around you you are amongst the
most empowered and proactive individuals
on the planet you are committed to
designing a life that is true to who you
are and your unique purpose
[Music]
be curious and keep learning I am now
embarked on a new set of learnings in
new fields that I have been curious
about for no good reason except I think
it's just the best use of my time I
think you all should do that as well
[Music]
it's very easy to opt out it's very easy
to get discouraged and give up but if
you kind of have the mentality the
basically says it kind of doesn't matter
how many times you get knocked down the
key thing is to just keep getting back
up and keep swinging
you